e
e e
I would like to welcome everybody to
the New Hampshire fishing game
committee we're looking forward to uh
hearing any questions you have and being
able to answer what we
can I heard that you all met already
with the federal Mid-Atlantic Fisheries
commission with us being further north
we um we actually use the North Atlantic
that we talk about more often and that's
a different commission but they work the
same so it's the same sort of situation
with them making federal laws that
do um give us governance uh and
guidelines over the fishing in our North
Atlantic Oceans whether they be intern
National Waters
uh federal waters or state
waters and
um I guess that's all I've got I will
let the rest of my committee now
introduce themselves and then I'll
introduce myself as as we go by as uh
actually I'll do it right now I'm
chairman James Spain uh I represent the
towns of Deerfield Candia and Auburn
here in New Hampshire I'm serving my uh
10th year
fifth term all of us are reelected every
two
years and um I will be running for a
sixth term and with that I'll toss it
over to representative
tutor welcome um representative tutor I
represent Rockingham 1 which includes
the towns of Northwood and Nottingham
I'm in my fourth year or my second term
as a state representative and I also
plan on rerunning
mention your Dees background I will uh
good morning all welcome uh my name is
Carol Brown uh I come from a small town
in the middle of New Hampshire I
represent two towns with a total
of maybe 4,000 constituents
only um I come to uh I'm in my first
term so this is my second year I'm a
biologist by
education I worked for the State of New
Hampshire in the Department of
Environmental Services in hazardous
waste and in wastewater treatment and
the last 15 years in oil spill response
uh particularly concentrating on damages
to Marine environments and uh uh
recovery from those
damages and nice to have you all here
welcome good morning and welcome my name
is Mike wette I am in my my first term
here in New Hampshire
house I live in the Northern I'm the
northernmost representative in the state
of New Hampshire I live abing the state
of Vermont and very very close to the
Canadian
border thank
you with that if uh you'd like we can
kick it off to you to uh ask any
questions um I will tell you that uh we
don't have a lot of impact
on um poaching commercially of fish in
New Hampshire we govern what we do here
just the state waters and most of that
is uh laws that govern um the landing of
fish um the landing of of lobsters crabs
and
such um regulations about uh what kind
of gear can be used while fishing within
those state
waters um outside of the state waters we
have federal waters those are governed
by um the federal laws not the state
laws and uh and then beyond that of
course is the international
waters and with that I'll let your
moderator decide who gets to ask the
first questions or what's a topic of
importance that one of us might be able
to answer for you
that's a good question um we do not have
term limits in New Hampshire because we
are a volunteer legislature we are
actually uh 400 in number in the state
house and 24 in the
Senate uh we also have an executive
Council made up of five and the governor
himself and all of us run every two
years so the entire government could
turn over every two
years um because there's so many of us
as a citizen legislature and we are
actually number three in size in the
democratically elected English-speaking
world
behind our own federal government and
the House of Commons in
England um that puts our representation
very close to the people and we have to
do a good job or they're going to kick
us out on top of that
um we we have high turnover I think
about the the numbers average about
onethird of the house doesn't come back
every election cycle so uh it's just one
of those those things where at some
point someone will make a decision that
they are done and they don't want to run
anymore because it's a lot of work to do
and we only get paid $100 a year for it
and that's before taxes so this isn't a
career we don't get paid large amounts
of money for being here and there's no
in incentive for us to make a career out
of it uh what we do we do simply because
we want to make things better and be
able to volunteer to help our state out
with its
governance and
I'll let uh each person answer in their
own to the same question if anybody's
got anything to
add quite question
but oh ter liament um I I really think
that New Hampshire uh government is is
representative of how the founding
fathers wanted it to be set up they
wanted us to be even at the federal
level citizen legislators who left the
private sector went and served the
people for a short period of time and
then went back to the private sector um
I don't think the founding fathers ever
meant for Washington to become what it
may have become which is a full-time job
and so I think New Hampshire is probably
very close to what our founding fathers
really
wanted sure I would add just a little
more to to what they said and I think
that uh this is only my second year here
but I've seen that because it's all
volunteer there's a real pride in the
people that are here to to serve the
people of the state and as a volunteer
and it's really it's an honor to be here
truly
is I agree it is an honor but it is a
tremendous commitment uh a lot of the
representatives live uh quite a ways
away as myself it's almost 3 hours uh
driving time to come here and uh so you
have to be dedicated at the same time
you have to be looking at the big
picture that you really want to help
your constituents and do what's right
for your area so it is uh uh we take a
lot of pride in what we
do I am wudi Baki kuruma from the Civil
Society organization of serun now the
question I would like to ask about this
the election of this legislative in a
situation we are in the American
politics is being navigated by two
political parties like Democrats and
Republicans how do you go about the
election of your local
legislations is this on partisan basis
or
what yes
so it is and when this house finishes
its elections there will be a certain
number of the house members who are
Democrats and a certain number who are
Republicans um we're not showing you
that division right now because everyone
who showed up today here is is
Republican um
but currently our house is evenly
divided we only have a majority of about
three Republicans at the moment so all
of these committees are set up to
represent the entire body in numbers so
my committee has 10 Republicans and 10
Democrats on it that makes up the 20
that sit here normally to do our
committee work when we look at laws they
may be submitted by either side what
we're looking at is what's best for the
state sometimes politics plays into that
this committee not so much because we
are uh less of a controversial or or
very partisan committee uh when we make
a decision on a law it's typically
because it's having to do with the
management of our wildlife and both
sides usually agree on
that um and
so other things that we deal with in the
house can be very partisan um the
laws as they come forward can be very
slanted one side or the other and then
you get fights over them but I think
that this committee is one where uh
typically you get more of a um
discussion
over people who might be more leaning
towards anti-hunting anti-fishing more
animal rights versus people who are
hunters and fishermen and and um looking
out for the the fishing industry and and
uh our hunting tourism and and that sort
of thing so uh that tends to be the
conservationist and animal rights versus
the Sportsman's rights and Commercial
rights and I think I would it there and
see if anybody else has something to
add yeah I think that today because we
are so um close in numbers we are more
partisan and than maybe um or
nonpartisan I should say than than maybe
we normally are uh because in order to
get any legislation through we have to
work together uh there's no way one side
can can rule the house and and say this
is the way it's going to be because we
don't have the numbers to do that and uh
so to some extent this creates you know
an even house creates a nonpartisan
environment because just you have to
have that in order to legislate when we
have a stronger majority we might be
more part tend to be more partisan
because we don't need the other side to
pass
legislation one thing I found being on
the committee it's very very interesting
like myself I live up north I live in
the mountains and being part of this
committee I've got a a great education
on how our Sea Coast works and our
commercial fishermen which I've never
had any exposure to so as we work
together it's very interesting it's
still very
educational very quickly I would add
that there there there is uh an
independent party third party it's it's
for those people that don't want to be
over here or over here and they kind of
in the middle more of the times it's a
very small number of people and they
they don't have any they don't really
have much sway as a group I don't even
how many we have three or four maybe
currently we only have two or three okay
okay um so there there is that option to
be a a a third party but it's uh it's
generally not going to get you anywhere
to do that and when we run for
election I will say that there has not
been success in this state for people to
run as a third party and get elected um
everyone who is currently an independent
in the house became that after they were
already elected and they just decided
they didn't want to be part of either
party
anymore they dropped out of the other
parties and declared that they were
independent when we run for reelection
which is coming up very
soon we sign up as either a Republican
or a Democrat you could sign up as an
independent but whenever someone's done
that in the past they don't end up
getting enough votes and they just don't
they don't end up in the house so we do
have a situation here where those small
numbers of people who are independent
tend to run as one party or the other
and then declare that they're
independent once they're here
okay
[Music]
en development
thank you for that question that's a
good one um we did not actually mention
yet our Department of Fish and Game and
Marine Resources which is what we're
here to actually do our entire focus of
this committee is to
shape
renew abolish if needed the laws that
they work to enforce so the Department
of Fish and Game and Marine
Resources is made up of um people who
who deal with the licensing aspect but
then also those enforcement
officers and we have uh enforcement on
our Sea Coast where they enforce our uh
laws regarding commercial fishering
fishing commercial uh crab and lobster
and then also the Sportsman fishing on
the Sea
Coast on the mainland and up in the
mountains we have a lot of enforcement
officers that deal with hunting uh
whether it be big game small game um the
the use of uh allterrain vehicles uh
four-wheelers and snowmobiles and other
things that we use to drive because
those are not on a road they're not
enforced by the police they're enforced
by the fish and game officers so any
laws that we've put in place that govern
how those Vehicles can be operated on
trails in woods Fields Etc are enforced
by that department so our our fish and
game department is
um extensive but we obviously need more
people than we have because we have a
lot of land mass in New Hampshire and
I'm not sure what the current number is
one of these guys might be able to pitch
in with it but uh we have we have a
number of fishing game officers on staff
now that are spread out around the state
some of them dealing only with those
Inland areas um I forgot to mention
Inland we have fishing in The Lakes so
they're also not just doing the hunting
and the trails but they're doing the
freshwater fishing as opposed to the
Marine fishing in the
ocean uh then we've got our boats and
our crews out on the ocean that are
doing the enforcement and the checking
when a commercial boat comes in to make
sure this they're complying with laws
Etc and of course some of the what we
enforce on our Sea Coast for that
commercial is governed by federal law so
they're working under both state law and
federal law when they when they are
working with
that um and with that I'll pass it along
again yeah I would just add that um
though fishing game takes the lead on
that enforcement any of our Law
Enforcement Officers whether that be
State Police local Police or Sheriffs uh
have the power to enforce those laws as
well so if they were to see something
that they thought was a Miss they could
notify fishing game and and hold those
people until fishing game arrived to
make the final decision on whether or
not they had uh broken a regulation or a
law
I believe uh our current number of of
conservation officers in the field right
now is 46 and uh they're looking to
increase it by a few um one uh thing
that they do that um doesn't get a lot
of uh accolades is we uh hiking in the
in the mountains is very very good sport
and we have a lot of people from
Southern New England that come uh
hundreds of thousands of people
throughout the year and they lead up all
um rescue and lost hiker rescues um at
no charge as part of their program uh so
it's a it's a big part of the safety
part of it and we're very lucky we have
them listening to
you uh I was told I think that you have
met Federal representatives from the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration from
Noah and from the US Coast Guard so Noah
does not have an enforc ment Branch but
the Coast Guard as you know has an
enforcement branch and they are
responsible for certain issues on the
coast uh by federal law they're
responsible for environmental issues oil
spills hazardous waste bills within a
certain distance of the
shoreline um the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services so
I'm sure that you all have slightly
different breakdowns of of uh of the
jurisdictions that are
Forest the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services handles water
quality um illegal discharges to to
rivers and streams and to the ocean and
that type of thing but we do not have an
environmental
police they have to follow those up with
civil basically Court actions to to
manage that so the Coast Guard is our
basically they they obviously have a law
enforcement capability
[Music]
mer PR question
so to recap the question because you
didn't get to hear it um and I'm sorry
I'm not doing that last time uh he's
wondering about the breakdown of the
parties and if the political parties
have
um if they contest and and um argue over
the allocation of the resources for the
the um fishing and and and that type of
thing and for example uh you know shrimp
comes in underneath the um the fishing
and um do we have specific laws that
deal with the baking of shrimp and
things like that
so uh I think I caught all of
it we have we do tend to have a
breakdown in the political
parties for some of what gets allocated
for this the laws that this committee is
is responsible for as I said we tend to
be a fairly bipartisan party but if you
had to break it down I I think that the
Republican party you would find is more
Pro
business um trying to take and and be
behind those commercial fisheries and
fishermen to make sure they can make a
living and make uh the best use of our
resource for um commercial purposes and
for business purposes so that people
have a livelihood and in
income um on the Democrat side they
would tend to break down more on the
animal rights issues um the restriction
on Commercial Fishing uh the restriction
on methods of fishing to make it more
fair for the animal being
caught um and less concern about the
actual
industry and I would sum it up that way
I think on the breakdown so if we have a
law for example on that might come
forward um that says we're going to
restrict the way that somebody can fish
for blue fish off of our sea
Coastline it might get a little
contentious between parties because you
might have um the Democrat side saying
um they want to protect the Bluefish and
they're going to restrict the use of
certain types of
Nets whereas we would be saying what's
the evidence that there's any harm being
done by these
nets we want to protect the industries
that are depending on those blue fish to
be brought in and it's it's a balancing
act we want to try to protect of course
the resource because without the
resource there won't be an industry in
the future but at the same time we don't
want to so restrict the industry that
they cannot make a living doing it um we
don't have a shrimp industry up this far
north to the best of my knowledge the
shrimp are more of a warm water species
we have main
lobster I don't know if you guys have
been able to have any Lobster while you
were here but Main Lobster is a
different species than that southern
Lobster that they have down in Florida
and whatnot and it's much better it's a
cold water
species um we also have
crab but to the best of my knowledge
there's no shrimp industry up here um
and I hope I caught enough answer for
everything there but I will pass it
along
now I I hope that I'm answering your
question but if there is contention and
so say fishing game committee comes to
agreement and we pass it out of
committee and then we bring it to the
house floor there may be disagreement
there and and so even there that we
manag to get agreement and we pass it
through the house it then has to go to
the
Senate and there's 24 Senators who have
to agree that it's a good law and when
they pass it it then goes to the
governor and he has to sign it or he can
veto it and stop the law as well so
there there's quite a few steps to
actually get a law onto the books and
then if the governor does veto it we
have the ability to override his be veto
but it takes a much larger vote than the
simple
majority representative
wette when we talk about politics and
contention it always seems to be the
factor of money that's involved now
fishing game department in the state of
New Hampshire is self funded through the
hunters and Fisherman's licenses it
takes very very little State money to
run this department the hunters and
fishermen support this uh uh Department
fund it so the the department has an
obligation of course to to do what's
best to um manage their Wildlife and
Fish but at the same time to uh work
with conservation to make sure that the
uh natural resources are well protected
okay that's an easy one
um when we run for reelection if we get
reelected we get sworn in in January of
the next year so for example this summer
we will be running elections in November
we will have those
elections in December this term of the
current members ends and in January we
start a brand new term with new all the
new members sworn in and at that point
when they're sworn in they get a check
for $200 to cover their two years you
don't get anything extra for the
committee you do get reimbursed for
mileage to drive here so someone like
representative ulette who's driving
three hours gets a larger amount of
money because he has to spend it all to
get down here
um and we do have some special
situations where there's some discounts
at the local hotels so if we had a lot
of days in a row representative ulette
might decide he's going to stay here
rather than drive all the way back and
forth and part of his mileage could
cover his hotel stay to make sure he's
he's here for all of our time um so
there's no no extra for being in the
committee the Speaker of the House gets
an extra $50 and the president of the
Senate gets an extra $50 but the Senate
and the house are both paid the same
even though there's only 24 of them and
there's 400 of us we all only earn that
$100 a year and that's before they take
the taxes
out of committee or to put it better how
do you work with other law enforcement
AG
we don't have prosecution powers in the
committee fish and game has prosecution
powers and their prosecution powers are
the same as any other law enforcement
officer in the state in fact they take
the same training they graduate from the
same courses it's just a different
department for them to go into where
they then specialize in the huge amount
of laws that we have for fishing game um
in
fact reptor do you think you can grab
one of our Fish and Game books from the
uh from the office so we can show them
how thick how thick the law book
is um they specialize in learning every
law regarding commercial and
recreational fishing hiking
four-wheeling everything that's in there
they specialize on that after they've
decided to become part of that
department department but they undergo
the same basic training and they have
the same prosecution ability the same
arresting ability and um and then our
regular court system handles it just as
they do anything else we don't have a
special court system
either you can pass that around and let
everybody take a look at
that and so at that point now I'll let
representative oulette answer as far as
the
prosecution represent Spain is correct
fishing game themselves the department
does that we have no power but if
there's something that changes in the
industry or in the sport and they need
new laws to do prosecution and to handle
their job that's where they come to us
to say hey we need this law changed
they'll bring it to us as a committee
we'll look at it maybe change it maybe
not vote on it take it to the floor and
try to get the law changed to give them
the tools to do the job that they
need and I can add on to that by giving
you some examples that we just did this
year so this year um the federal
government made a change last December
on the issuance of water fowl hunting
stamps now in the United States
migratory water fowl are governed by the
federal laws not a state law because
they travel across many states so the
federal law governs all hunting of them
and what laws can be in place we have
State LA laws that mimic those federal
laws so that they're enforceable within
our state but they're the ones who tell
us what it has to be for those so one of
the things they do with Federal water
fowl is in order to fund their program
they force everybody who plans to hunt
them to buy a tax stamp and it used to
be for many years
well for as long as the program's been
in in place until last year you got a
physical stamp that you had to sign your
name across and carry with you while
were hunting water foul and last
December the federal government decided
we're going to go with electronic ones
that just get sent to your phone and you
just have to show them the stamp stamp
on your phone and our law said you had
to sign that stamp and carry it with you
so we had to change our law because they
couldn't enforce the federal law with
the way our law was written and they
couldn't enforce our law when the
federal law said we're not giving you a
stamp anymore people would have no stamp
so we had to pass that one and that was
again there was no partisan issue there
everybody agreed we've got to do this so
that we are in line and it can be
enforced uh and that's just one
example in my first term here I've been
I've been very pleased with the demeanor
of all of the representatives that come
here to conquer occasionally you have an
issue but what you don't see here is
what you see on CNN or or any other
major Network about the challenging
hearings that happen in the US House of
Representatives and the Senate we don't
challenge people here we don't fight
with anyone that's sitting at this table
we're here to listen and I'm really
pleased that that's how it works in New
Hampshire one of
the uh one of the things that we can do
as members
is we generally have direct contact with
a a head of an agency so the director of
fishing game or the commissioner of an
agency so although we don't have
prosecutorial Powers we do have the
ability to pass our constituents
concerns directly to the head of an
agency and maybe have it taken care of
more quickly for them
I will speak in
French uh so my name is I'm from Morocco
[Music]
Secret
before we can get the final
agreement another another really great
question and I'm going to explain the
difference between rules and
laws what's in the law book that you saw
has rules and
laws our Department of Fish and Game and
Marine Resources the director of that
department has the ability to do certain
things under rules which happen much
faster than passing a law and we gave
them that ability because we have so
many many things that change constantly
as far as um hunting seasons fishing
Seasons the number of fish that can be
taken these things happen fast and it
might take a lot longer for a law to get
passed than the rule can be
changed
so within the fishing game department
the director may get biological data
from his employees that says we need to
decrease the number of trout being taken
this year in our freshwater areas
because we've had a decrease in their
numbers and we don't want people to take
too many or it could be something where
the federal government has decided that
we can't take as many of a certain type
of fish off our Shoreline or we may have
even decided we need to decrease the
number of lobsters being
taken uh it can also work with game uh
such as right now we have a large an
ever increasing population of turkeys so
recently they have changed the rules for
the turkey hunting season to allow you
to take two turkeys this spring instead
of just one like you could in the past
and you can still hunt one turkey in the
fall um but they've decided that there's
so many they need to take more of them
if they can so they're letting people
hunt more of them uh many many years ago
the turkey was endangered so you weren't
allowed to take any at all so we've had
a very successful program of bringing
the turkey back back so successful now
that they are just everywhere and we're
going to be trying to balance that out
by allowing them to be taken more so a
rule is governed entirely by the
director and the fishing Game Commission
which is a group of elected well
appointed by the governor members from
all around the state I think there's 11
of them I think so 11 members sit on
this commission they represent districts
up north where rep ulette is they
represent districts down here where I am
and there's a special one the number 11
is Sea Coast only that governs fisheries
and things on the Sea Coast so every
area gets representation on the fishing
Game
Commission so when the director goes to
set rules the commission votes on that
and if the commission representing all
of the state agrees there's two public
hearings on it somewhere in the state
the public gets to have an input but
then all of that stuff is set down into
the rules and that makes up for the next
hunting and fishing season so that it's
done every year uh any major changes go
through that process we don't have to
take care of that in law because it it
just wouldn't get done um but we have to
shape the laws that
overall um
govern the fishing game department and
the commission such as uh and and with
our laws we're able to override the
commission so if the commission doesn't
think something is a good idea we can
pass a law that says we don't care we
want to do it anyway um an example of
that would be a law I passed uh for so
years ago that allowed the use of a
crossbow for hunting during the muzzle
loader season when you were only
supposed to use muzzle loading rifles
there was no impact to anything except
that it gave people a different option
to use but the commission was opposed to
it they didn't want to allow it and we
passed the law through the house and the
Senate and the governor signed it so now
it's a law they have to craft rules to
follow that law and that took longer to
do it can take an entire year or maybe
both years in a
session um or in a term I should say and
um so it could take one or two years
typically if something goes longer than
two years you're now into a new elective
cycle so everything could get turned
upside down and it may not go anywhere
um so we try to get everything done if
it's a law within one or two years but
those rules can happen very
quickly and anybody else have anything
to add to
that just one more thing when we talk
about the fish and gaming Department you
know we've mentioned a lot about law
enforcement but they've got a whole
section in their Department of just
biologists who are studying our animal
habitat and our fisheries and um give
recommendations on the laws and what
should be changed and what we need to do
to protect
them yeah the
um the biologists are the ones who give
the scientific data
guidance to the ru making and the law
making when it comes to questions about
what we should should do to best
preserve the habitat for the species to
preserve the species whether it be ocean
habitat Lakes mountains we have a wide
variety of biologists who are constantly
studying that and that can even impact
things such as Housing
Development logging for
Timber all of these things might have an
impact that then has to be studied
before the decision can be made by those
biologists
mer
Jonathan repic Dem
hello
see
H Oru
problem
M
see that one's a complicated one but
we'll get to it
yes so um we don't have a Ministry or a
parliament in the United States we are a
representative
Republic that means that we are a
republic that's brought together
together by a whole bunch of States who
agreed to enter into this Republic the
federal
government governs
overarching laws defense of the nation
as a
whole but a lot of power is invested in
each individual
state within the states some of us run a
little differently but we all follow the
same way without a parliament or without
a
Ministry every single position in our
state government is elected on its
own so it it doesn't matter if the
governor is Republican or Democrat that
Governor got
elected and that's his party or her
party the same is true with the
executive councel which is a check on
the balance of the governor the governor
cannot do everything that Governor wants
unless five the five members of the
executive Council agree with him a
majority of them for example appointing
someone to be director of Fish and Game
he may make an appointment of someone to
be the director of this department but
the executive Council has to look at
that listen to have a hearing on that
and agree with him or else it doesn't
happen in the Senate and the house we
are a
bamal legislative body
we are equal but
separate the Senators have districts
that overlap hours so the same people
who are voting for us are voting for a
senator and a governor and an executive
council
member they may not all be from the same
party but we have to work together if
we're going to get things
done so for example in my district I
have three towns I
cover in my hometown of Deerfield my
Senator that runs in my district his
district uh is one area so currently
that would be representative or Senator
Pearl in the next town over that I also
represent
Candia I have a different Senate
District overlaps that so I've got
Senator Murphy there and in my third
town I have yet another Senate District
because I live in a complicated area
and I have Senator Carson over
there all three of them happen to be
Republicans but it doesn't have to be
that way one of the towns could have
elected me as a republican but elected a
Democrat as the
senator and so everything is elected at
its own
level and the way that things move
through our body to get done is that
first we write some what's called a bill
which is an idea for a
law in the house or the
Senate all tax bills spending and money
bills need to originate by law in the
house not the
Senate because they're closer to the
people we have much more of a direct
interaction because there's 400 of us
rather than
24 there's one of us for every 3,500
people in the state so they figured
money has to be close to the people
we're not going to let you tax people
unless they have a very direct say so we
propose a
bill it comes to a committee like
this we have a public Hearing in this
committee where the makeup is split
between Republicans and Democrats based
on how the election
went members of the public and special
interests and department heads can all
come in and testify to us on the bill we
listen to them we will at a later time
have discussions among the committee
members on what we've heard from
testimony and make a vote if we decide
that that bill should proceed on it goes
to the house floor with an ought to pass
or we think it's good motion if we think
it shouldn't go forward it goes to the
house floor with a itl which means
inexpedient to legislate or we shouldn't
pass it
motion I'm simplifying this a little bit
but um once it passes the house it still
has to go to the Senate and the Senate
will bring it in front of a committee on
their side like this where they will
hear from the public and the department
heads and
everybody they will make their
discussions and
determination and then it goes to the
senate floor if it passes the senate
floor and it's the same as the bill
passed the house it goes to the governor
the governor can choose to sign it or
not and that's how you have to go
through to get the legislation done and
how we have to all work together any
anything that started in the Senate as a
bill still has to come to the house and
we have to pass it before it goes to the
governor so we're equal bodies we just
represent different areas of the state
with different numbers and we still have
to work together and so there's no
Parliament I would say for us the
parliament well like in in England they
have the Parliament and the House of
Commons right house of House of Lords
and the House of Commons make up the
parliament that's it so for your
terminology Parliament equals
legislature the House of Lords would be
the Senate and the House of Commons
would be those of us in the
house
and we don't elect a speaker based on
Coalition of parties but we do have a
vote for who's going to run each of
those bodies um it's typically the
majority who had seats in that body will
elect their person to run that body so
This this term we had slightly more
Republicans and we elected speaker
Packard to be our Speaker of the House
in the Senate they had slightly more
Republicans and they elected Senator Jeb
Bradley to be the president of the
Senate and those two people are in
charge of keeping everybody in order
keeping everything running the speaker
on the house side and the Senate
President on the Senate side and there
they're the ones who instill
order and
decorum and
agenda anything to
add as representa Spain said in the
house our speaker of the house is was
elected is a gentleman named Sher
Packard when I was first elected to the
house we had the election I was very
much surprised that he was elected
overwhelmingly um with a lot of
Democrats voting for this Republican
speaker and that just showed that how
much respect there is for people who
work
together so I I believe I've translated
your question from listening to the
Chairman's answer to
you um in the history of the United
States the idea of the House of of at
the federal level the house of repres
representatives and the Senate was
similar to English parliament in many
ways the House of Lords and the House of
Commons the thought was in the founding
of the country that the House of
Representatives was more of the Common
Man the farmer the worker and they
tended to be maybe a little more
uh controversial Rough Around the Edges
controversial and the senators were
always supposed to be those that were
higher bred and could control themselves
and they could kind of temper what the
House of Representatives
did I we have grown far from that at
this point and and basically the House
of Representatives and the Senate are
are people from all walks of life at
this point although some of those in
certain positions do think they're
better than others still in this day and
age but
mhm yeah and just quickly there are
times when the house sends a bill to the
Senate after we have approved it and the
Senate changes it it then has to come
back to the house and we vote to uh
either concur with their
change to no we're not interested in
what you've done non-c concur or we can
ask for a committee of conference where
we will get together and try to work out
a compromise
uh to pass the bill so that's the the
other part of
it
yes now uh again W Kura again from seron
now uh looking at the illegal unreported
and unregulated Fisheries
activities that has now ped the threat
towards the management of our fishies
resources I want to know in the first
place how does this
States take note of the mes size the
area where people do the fishes
activities and the method they use to
fish that is one and
secondly how which policies are using do
you have open access to these resources
or you have restrictive measures that
you put in place like for my country is
an Open Access everybody can come to
there and do fishing without any
restriction then the last thing talking
about food security how this sector
contribute to all food security now we
know the exal which are the small scale
fishes their contribution towards this
particular aspect of food security which
policies do you have at state level to
subsidize these people whether yearly or
at any time you
wish I'm going to do my best here
um we have
when it comes to restrictions for
fishing or for anything else um that's
all done through licensing and
permitting so we do control because the
federal government also wants control
over the fisheries and the
resource um there was a
time 12 or 15 years ago when anybody
from New Hampshire could go and throw a
fishing line into the ocean and fish
with no license needed because the ocean
was different if they wanted to do it in
freshwat they needed a license or a
permit but not the ocean but the federal
government wanted us to start
restricting more of that so now you need
to buy a fishing license even to fish in
the
ocean we have multiple aspects of
that you have the what we consider sport
fishermen which is fishing for your own
use it may not really be sport it may be
for your food but you're fishing for
your own own use you're not selling it
and then we have commercial
fishermen who are fishing because
they're bringing it in to sell
it they're licensed differently and
they're monitored and controlled
differently um there's much less
regulation around a sport
fisherman because they're taking in less
fish um but there's still restrictions
on types of gear that can be used used
some of these things come down from
federal law such as no use of Gil Nets
um
and the types of lobster traps that can
be used and what must be on them for
safety equipment to let the lobsters be
able to escape if the Trap is
abandoned that kind of thing is is set
up in our law to mirror what the
Government Federal Government said they
needed to have
done there's there's no ability to have
completely open access you can't just go
out and start catching fish or hunting
animals without a license with the
exception of if you own a bunch of land
you can hunt on your own
property but you still subject to the
limits of the law in the state such as I
can still only take one deer in the
season if I take it on my property I
just don't have to pay for the deer tag
and license I can use a tag that's free
to take my deer and tag it uh that
doesn't extend to things like hunting
bear or turkey I would still have to buy
those tags I can't hunt them free on my
own land because those are a differently
managed
resource so I would say
overall that thick book that was going
around is full of
restrictions that prevent you from being
able to just freely go out and fish or
hunt as
needed and so hunting and fishing
doesn't tie into our state's food
security food Security in the state is
um governed more by the state when
somebody has an inse a food insecurity
in their family they apply for state aid
and they get uh vouchers to be used to
purchase groceries and food with the
state tax dollars helping to subsidize
them to keep to to supplement their food
security we don't uh just say here's a
hunting license go out and get something
we we give them a voucher to a grocery
store and they go through it that
way uh I think that was pretty much
everything that you were asking about
but I'll pass it along as
well all of our fishermen especially in
the uh fresh water I'll have to have a
license and it's amazing that they take
great PR
and following the laws because we know
that the license money goes to help
support the sport and the Fisheries when
someone is out there breaking the law
over limits not having a license there's
a lot of Social and and uh pressure to
get these guys caught because the the
the hunters and fishermen really take a
lot of pride in being the
conservationist of the state
so uh to to clarify our fishing game Law
Enforcement Officers they do have arrest
capability and if necessary they can
arrest on site however and and they are
allowed to walk up to you and say show
me your license and let me look in your
fish bag and see what you have and tell
me how you caught that they have the
they have the right by law to do that
and they can pull your license and they
can at at the minimum send you home and
say you can't fish anymore but so they
do have the authority to to enforce laws
in the field but as as representative
wette said I think that the community of
of uh fishing game users takes a lot of
pride in making sure that we protect the
resource that everyone is involved in
that yeah I'm not sure I really caught
the question but I will add BAS on the
ansers that
um as a landowner I'm allowed to post my
property and uh make it so that you
can't hunt on it or fish on it um most
New Hampshire land owners do not do that
they leave their property open for the
public to come and Hunt um and uh
there's a program called current use
where I they the state gives me a little
bit of break on my taxes on the property
for allowing recreational use of my
property to the to the residents of the
state and that that brings me into a
good point that I should explain about
how our state property works because
this this is important we're very
different from some of the other states
in the Midwest of the United States and
such here in New England in the
northeast of the United States we have
since colonial times always been working
under the the guidance of communal prop
property so although I own
property everybody who takes and does
Recreation of hiking walking fishing or
hunting can go on any other property
without permission as long as it's not
posted by the landowner that says they
don't want someone on it all of the land
is open to use in New Hampshire for all
people unless it's specifically posted
by the landowner that you can't go on it
so uh and as as uh representative Tudor
said in order to encourage more of that
use um if you've got a large property of
land a large amount of property or land
um you can get a break on your taxes an
extra 15% discount on your taxes uh if
you leave it open to all Recreations and
don't post it um that is something
that's been highly guarded and respected
here because it means that you don't
have to actually sign a lease with
someone to be able to go and hunt or
sign or or fish on their property it's
open to everybody to use and as such
every person here in the state feels
like we have a shared interest in all
the resources so we're all conserving
them because they apply to all of
us
um and uh anybody else have anything to
add on to that part of it no all right
so that that's how we we run our shared
property uh values in the midwest if I
was going to go hunting somewhere their
default is you can't hunt on anyone
else's property unless you have written
permission whether it's posted or not so
if I go out there for a hunting trip
I've got to actually pay someone money
and sign a lease with them for
permission to use their land to hunt or
fish on um and in in our area up here in
the Northeast we follow a different
model and it's uh the Northeast model of
of Land Management that um allows for
shared use of the land unless a
particular land owner says keep
out go ahead just an example of how
expansive this open permission is in the
state of New Hampshire there's over
5,000 miles of snowmobile trails with
over 80% of it on private land so it's
open to everyone year you know through
the winter
and quickly it might be worth
adding in this new technology that we
are
in those conversations have come a
little more complicated because people
have been putting their personal trail
cameras out on other people's property
that they are allowed to hunt on and the
property owners have been saying now
wait a minute now you're taking pictures
of me and my wife and my children on my
land and I don't want you to do that so
we had a bill come through last year to
that we had to deal with that so that
that has put a little bit of A Wrinkle
In This Open Access
discussion that's a good example of
where the the progress made in
technology caused us to have to
implement a new law because nobody wants
someone coming out and putting an
automatic camera on their own property
that can take pictures without their
permission or knowledge that it's
there um so we had to implement a
specific hunting regulation that says
that you can't go and put a camera on
someone else's property without their
permission um and if you do put it out
there that permission only lasts one
year you got to get new permission next
year you can't just do it all the time
and um on your own property though you
can put one out and keep it all you want
because it's yours
so
just okay
mer
me
[Music]
question
you
[Music]
exus
d
okay so the question is basically
multiples uh the first one was what
checks and balances are in place to
ensure that um agent agencies cannot do
whatever they want to violate those
people we
represent um and the second part was uh
how do we reconcile when we're
representing a community what if our
community is breaking the law how do we
how do we reconcile that and we
mentioned that uh the federal government
sometimes mandates something but we're
we have a different opinion have we have
have we had to pass legislation that is
in conflict with the federal law and how
do we manage that um it's very comp
licated one but it's a good question I
will uh start out by saying that
[Music]
um we are representing our communities
to the state from the local level to the
state but we also elect people that
represent the state down in the federal
government and so this whole process
this chain of of representative
government is something that in America
everybody adopts and buys into and for
the most part uh it's one of those
things where if a majority of the people
have elected a certain person to
represent them then we expect them to do
the best that they can for everyone in
the community and we realize that we
might be a minority of that and we might
not get what we
want
um as for the checks and
balances we have as Representatives
direct contact with the Department heads
of the
agencies if we hear that some of our
constituents are suffering an injustice
from an
agency we can escalate to the director
of that agency and if we don't get
satisfaction there we can always
escalate to the governor because he
appoints and governs all of those
agencies when it comes down to it every
agency in the state is reporting to the
governor and the executive Council
um
so we don't typically have an issue
where an agency is abusing a community
or doing what they want in a community
but we do have expectations that we've
put into law on how agencies should
behave and if they violate those
expectations we do have methods to
escalate to someplace who
at at the end the governor could remove
the director of that Agency for not
keeping his agency in
line um and even if it went far enough
could press charges and prosecute the
director of the agency for
violating um his contract under the law
with the
state
um the second half of the question uh
with representing our communities and
whether we have conflicts with federal
government yes um frequently we have
have found ourselves at odds with what
the federal government but it's one of
those things that changes depending on
who the administration is for the most
part I'll say one of the most blatant
examples really doesn't have anything to
do with fish and game but some states
within the United States have decided
that they don't like the federal
prohibition on use of
marijuana and they have implemented
local state laws and they have
said we as a state don't care if the
federal government said we can't do it
we're going to do it anyway because
we're not going to enforce the law here
in the
state now they call that legalization
but it's typically it's really not
legalization what it is is refusal to
prosecute and refusal to arrest by the
state so the federal government if they
want to enforce it is now at the point
where they have to send federal agents
in and use federal law enforcement
officers to enforce something and to be
frank there's not enough federal law
enforcement officers to enforce laws
like that in every state so if a state
comes forward like Colorado has done and
like Oregon has done and California and
says we're not going to prosecute people
for having marijuana and using it the
federal government is at that point
stuck with only Prosecuting and and
working against Crime of that if it's
big enough to attract their attention
the average person on the street they
just don't have the manpower to do it um
we had a bill a while back that uh was
another good
example when there was a fear that the
federal government might Implement some
form of gun control by executive order
that would take away our gun rights in
the state we in New Hampshire passed a
New Hampshire law that said none of our
law enforce ment in the state will
enforce any federal ban on
firearms that goes against our Second
Amendment right in our
Constitution and so any such attempt to
try to restrict Firearms within our
state would require the federal
government to send in their own Army of
people because our law enforcement were
going to be on our side they would be
defending our right to keep those guns
and that passed and was signed as well
um
I think I got everything but I'm going
to let other people pitch in here uh
representative
ulette the gentleman asked if you had a
local law enforcement that was really
running rough shot over the community
how would you deal with
it if I'm a fisherman and I don't think
I'm treated right have a ticket my next
step is to go to the local Court the
court judge there is nonpartisan and
follows the law and if you don't like it
you can always appeal but there's a
check and balance to keep that law
enforcement guy
intact one thing that uh represent Spain
said that we all have the ability to go
to the Commissioners and the directors
of these departments and and air our
griefs but the bottom line is we control
their funding so they listen pretty
well that's true we can take away their
money and then they have no money to get
paid to operate if they don't listen to
us and just Qui ahe I a higher level the
the way the states and the federal
government are supposed to work is
defined in the United States
Constitution the Constitution is really
the highest document that tells us what
rights we have as Citizens versus what
rights the government has and in that
Constitution is the 10th Amendment which
says that all things not referenced in
the Constitution are left for the states
to decide it is great debate as to how
that works but that that's really at the
highest level where the state gets its
power from and the ability to govern
itself sure um there there
are uh there are certainly times when
state agencies are conducting themselves
in a way that people don't agree
with I think a simple example outside of
fishing game is there are those that
believe maybe our environmental agency
is
allowing too simplified of a process to
site a new landfill which is a very hot
topic about where do you put your
waste so there are those that believe
that they're acting in concert in some
ways with the industry to site new
landfills which we haven't found any
direct evidence for but you bring that
forward as a check and balance that's
not something you would take to court
necessarily but it is something that you
would bring forward to your
representative or your Senator and say I
have a a problem with this agency I
believe that this is happening and then
we as Representatives or the Senators
will take that forward to the head of
the agency and if there's a problem
we'll work through the governor's office
and the Attorney General's office if
necessary so there there are certainly
times when the average person believes
that a an agency is not serving them in
the way they want and everybody has
their opinion of course so it does
happen and I think that we have a really
solid way of managing
that this is the final one for me now uh
with all the powers that the governor
has in the case where a governor comes
in as a governor of a state then he's
not working according to what the
constitution of that state says what
action do you as legislation has to take
against
him well um as an elected official the
governor has won his
seat however we can if if it was an
egregious enough um well we'll start
with a minor one if he's if he's doing
something minor that is disagreed with
the first people that would stop him is
the check and balance of the executive
counsel that's the five people that are
elected that control uh large budget
items that the governor May approve they
have to also approve it um appointments
of personnel uh to to the different
departments um they have to approve that
um they serve as the first check and
balance on the governor abusing his
power and we're one of the only states
that has that executive counil IL um
it's a hold over from our colonial days
when the king of England used to appoint
our
governor and the colonists here in New
Hampshire didn't like the way the
governor was
working and we were going to
rebel and in order to to calm us down
the king said I will let you have an
executive counil of people from your own
community that serve as a check and
balance against my Governor if you don't
have a
rebellion and we've kept that even in
the days of Elections now where we have
an elected executive Council that serves
as a check and a balance against the
direct the governor's direct immediate
power the other thing is the governor's
reelected every two
years
so if he screwed up bad enough he would
not get reelected in 2 years in some
states the governor's elected for six
years well that's a long time to be in
there if he's abusing his power two
years it's very easy to turn it over and
get rid of
him and then we always have the ability
to impeach if both the house and the
Senate agree in great enough numbers we
can run an
impeachment does that cover everything
V
[Music]
good question so that Carol that was
basically um wondering if we ever take a
recess where we can go back to our
communities to find out how things are
being applied and how things are working
there so we can get the input from the
people and first I'll say um unlike the
federal situation where people go down
to Washington and they may stay down
there and not come back here in New
Hampshire sure uh we're a small enough
State uh that the furthest someone has
to drive to be here is 3 hours and
um people live in that
Community when we come up here we come
up usually for our session once a week
from January to
June from June through the end of the
year we're mostly off and we're back in
our communities for that period of time
we do most all of our work from January
through
June um in addition every single day
that we're not here we're in our home
community and we're not here every day
five days a week from January to June
this committee doesn't meet as
frequently so we will be up here a few
Tuesdays between January and June for
our committee hearings and we'll spend
all day doing them and then we go home
and almost every Thursday we're here to
be in the house session in the big Hall
with all 400 people voting on the bills
that have been coming out of committees
or have been coming to us from the
Senate aside from those days we're home
some committees have more time in up
here and
conquered
um finances here a lot but they still go
home every night to their communities
and they still have have from June
through the end of the year that they
live in that community and they get to
hear directly from people all that time
that they're
there
repet what um represents Spain is
correct but remember we have to stay in
our communities because for $200 a year
if you're not retired we all have
full-time jobs and families and and
churches and things we're involved
within our communities
and then also in the electronic World
our constituents are never far from our
cell phones on email or texting us they
all have our phone numbers to call us um
so there's there are many means for our
constituents to uh communicate with us
and express the displeasure if if they
want
to for
so most of
us have another elected position or so
that we serve but it's not one that gets
paid um for example representative Brown
here is a selectman in his town do you
get any compensation there uh yeah I get
more than
here um yes I do
but but um I have a full-time day job
I'm a senior technical writer for an
industrial tools company that does
non-destructive inspection and uh X-ray
and ultrasonic inspections on things
like aircraft and windmills and things
like
that that's what I do full-time and
that's how I make my money the $100 a
year is in our constitution it'll not
get changed anytime soon we don't vote
ourselves AR raay like other states do
because it's in our Constitution that
means we need to have a majority of the
house 3 fifths to 3 fifths of the house
has to vote to pass an amendment to our
constitution to change what we get paid
then a three-fifths of the Senate has to
do the same and then it's got to go on
the ballot so that three-fifths of the
people in the state vote for it on their
election and then it could happen but
it's a very high bar and it's and it was
set way way back when $100 a year was
actually compens ation for a farmer to
come down here and miss some of his
crops being being pulled in now it's a
it's more of a thing of Pride for us
because we we work because we want to do
the work not because we're getting paid
to do it and that's why we consider
ourselves a volunteer
legislature um it's another reason we
don't need the term limits right at $100
a year how long are you going to put up
with it before you're like all right I'm
done I had my fill and I'm going to go
back to my day job and and whatnot um so
it it keeps us from needing term limits
nobody's a career
politician and um yes you can have you
can have other elected positions there
are some there are some qualifications
for that because you can't have a
conflicting one there's there's areas of
conflicted interest such as I could not
be a senator and a representative at the
same time I could not run for governor
and Senator and Senator or
representative at the same time um I
could not be the director of one of the
Departments and a representative at the
same
time
um there are some areas where you can't
be both but but in most cases
everybody's either retired from their
work and and they're doing this because
they're bored at home and they want to
come out and do something in conquered
that helps out the state or they've got
another
job and I've got business cards for
everybody here by the way from myself
that little bit I I would add to that
answer that there are there are those
that say the New Hampshire legislature
should be paid more because it tends to
be an old person's
legislature because we are mostly many
of us are retired or some of U many
folks like the chairman have the have
the option to to cut out a little bit
from work and change the work schedule
but yeah yes there are definitely those
that believe if we were paid more that
it would be a younger legislature and it
would allow more people to take part in
the process um but I think there is a
great deal of pride in the fact that we
are volunteers and that we we are doing
this for the greater
good I know that we're com close to the
end but would you have a very quick
question
from uh thank you
uh Mr
chairman I need I I need to know if you
have a national Marine fishery service
inside New Hampshire
State national Marine service within the
state
yeah we have connections to the National
marine fisheries but but that's through
our fishing game department we don't
actually have an office of national
marine fisheries here okay we have uh
also some members of the fishing
community on our Sea Coast that sit on
the North Atlantic marine
fisheries
Council um as advisers for what's good
for New Hampshire and they are fishermen
who have either retired or a current
fisherman so they have uh the best
interest of the industry of the
fishermen in mind when they're talking
with them uh of course fish and game is
going to be representing our biological
diversity and um uh sustainability of
our our species along the Sea Coast um
and the recreational fishermen more than
the commercial fisherman that the
fisherman that sits on the council would
so I don't know where they're
headquartered probably out of Boston
right I think so I think that they're
office their main office for the North
Atlantic marine fisheries Coalition uh
or council is out of Boston Mass which
is just about an hour south of
here
um I have a a slightly unrelated comment
our fish and game department has uh has
many of the uh similar agencies across
the
country created a television show which
shows you how the law enforcement
officers go around the state and do
their
business uh it's uh you can see them on
YouTube it's called Northwoods law it's
really interesting to see how the
Enforcement Officers deal with the
public and and the types of things that
that they have to manage on a day-to-day
basis um I think and and one of thing we
didn't talk about real quick is that our
fishing game Department's also
responsible for um search and rescue
when people are lost on the mountain
tops and that type of
thing yeah they they if anybody has any
questions on about how the law
enforcement aspect works that's a great
show to pick up on YouTube if you go out
and look at it uh if you look at
Northwoods law you'll see that's us and
that's our guys out in the field
checking license es doing a rescue uh
dealing with
poachers all of
that rouette our fishing gaming
department is really unique and a lot of
times Innovative in the last few years
they've really helped uh fishermen along
the coast develop an oyster farm and an
oyster business that never existed uh
which is very interesting um 50 years
ago there were relatively no moose in
New Hampshire we have a very healthy
moose population now that they've even
have hunting season uh again when I was
a young man there was no turkeys in New
Hampshire they made a deal with the
state of West Virginia West Virginia had
a problem with porcupines overrunning
their territory New Hampshire has a an
animal called a Fisher up here that eats
porcupines we switched trade them fishes
for turkeys now we've got a very healthy
turkey population here very Innovative
in a lot of their thoughts
do we have any other final questions
because I was told to let people know
we're starting to run out of time yeah I
would like uh my name is yunusa abuka
I'm from Cameroon and in the name of the
group I would like to thank you for
hosting us hosting us today and also for
taking your time to share with us how
the rules and regulation are put in
place in the new yare to ensure a good
management of fishing and fishing
related activity in the states and in
that regard I have a special request I
would like to know if it is possible to
have a copy of the
law in order to see what can be applied
in our respective count based in our
respective context from the regulation
that are implemented here in the state
yeah once again thank you for having us
and for taking your time to share with
us all of this thank you so
much thank you I I actually was going to
ask our our uh committee clerk if if we
had uh copies I'd like to get you at
least uh one per country uh that you can
share if I can um I know that uh several
of my members were given some this year
that they didn't pick up so we might
have some extras uh but I don't think
the box is still in the office is you
know the whole box full of them was in
there I'll see if the if we can get a
copy
and if we can't get this year's copy
I'll at least get you the one from last
year before it was updated yeah sure
thanks um and how many copies do we need
we've got 1 two 3 four five
six seven seven visitors yeah but how
many individual countries if we had to
do just countries six okay so six or
seven I'll try to get the seven if we've
only got to squeeze out one extra that's
fine all right um anybody else have
anything from the committee I want to
thank you all for coming and and I think
it's it's fantastic to be able to share
like this um I was really happy to hear
a lot of questions that I could answer
that had to do with uh how things work
legislatively um I was a little
concerned at first that we might not be
able to discuss too much of what might
impact your country as far as fishery
poaching and things because we don't
have that same type of a situation here
but it seems like we've been able to
provide information to a lot of
different questions that I found really
enlightening um I I would Echo that it's
we're so you're so welcome and it's it's
it's quite amazing to have you all here
I it's a it's been a distinct pleasure
to be here I don't live too far from
where you're going to be tomorrow at the
New Hampton Fish Hatchery and maybe I
will come by and meet you there and and
listen to their presentation as well but
thank you all so very much for being
here and again thank you I I think these
type of uh sharing agreements uh work
out very well for both of us we learn as
much from you as you learn from us and
uh we really appreciate you taking the
time to come all this way to see
us
last thank you and safe
travels thank you